[Music]
hi there so I am Madeline and I am here
to talk to you about forging a path in a
web application that was built without
accessibility in mind as a novice who
knew sort of the basics of accessibility
but had only really seen it implemented
in simple applications or from the
ground up and I basically didn't really
know what I was doing here but I thought
that my journey might help some of you
because I feel like this is the story
that a lot of developers have where
they're thrown into an application that
exists already that is pretty complex
and was built without this layer in mind
without inclusion for everyone in mind I
work at ole arc we make a chat widget
that sits on your site so that you can
talk to those who visit your site and
this is a really amazing thing that
allows your site to be more usable for
someone who is having issues with your
technology or who can't find that help
article and I think it was really
important to make chat usable for
absolutely everyone especially those who
might be able to benefit from chat the
most so ooh why accessibility why is
this something that we talk about why am
i talking about it why should you care
why is this important there are lots of
reasons that people talk about it I am
not really going to talk about any of
them because I think that this is way
less important than the fact that
everyone should be able to use the web
the web is this magical place where you
can accomplish things that you wouldn't
be able to otherwise where you can
connect with people that you wouldn't
know otherwise where you have access to
information that you didn't even know
was out there and the fact that some
large portion tens of millions of people
in the US alone based on surveys and
statistics so I guess I'd mentioned one
of them are unable to use the web
effectively so I'm gonna revisit this
question again later but I'm going to
talk about that that was the Y that I
just talked about it's talked about the
what of this problem what is web
accessibility about and when I started
my project I thought this was about
following that map about looking at that
path that was already forged before me
and making it a little bit wider making
sure that you know the brush was out of
the way and that someone could you know
reasonably follow after me so this meant
meeting a lot of standards and then
being compliant with these rules that
someone else had had made up and I
thought that this was a major blocker on
me shipping I thought okay I had to meet
absolutely everything I had to make sure
that this works with every technology
every screen reader every operating
system every browser I have to make sure
that every single element on my page is
reachable by the keyboard and so that
boils down to rules I'm a rule follower
it's just how I'm wired and so when I
see this list of things I'm like okay
well I do this and then I do this then I
do this and that's how I accomplish this
thing is by following these rules
easy-peasy oh one quick thing I am going
to be talking about screen reader usage
mostly there are plenty of other ways to
make your application accessible but
this is the main thing that I attacked
in this application given my limited
resources so I had these epic X
Haitians in the back of my mind I had
these rules that I was going to follow
here's a picture of me on an actual
backpacking trip and now I have to
decide what goes with me on that trip
what tools do I have with me already
just with me what do I pack in my bag to
help me forge that path and then maybe
build a bridge so that you know everyone
can see the wonderful views and everyone
can hit the amazing checkpoints
throughout this forest that isn't an
accessible app and I wasn't really sure
what should go in that pack from the
beginning because how do you approach
this real-world abstract problem in this
inaccessible application started in 2007
or 2009 that I mean you know what legacy
code is like it's it's been through many
different versions and it's been built
upon and built upon and built upon and
there are many layers involved and then
there's this additional layer with our
chat box where it sits on sites that we
have no control over and so to make sure
that it works with other people's stacks
and it makes make sure that it works
again with different browsers and
different technologies but something
that I had in the back of my mind and I
wasn't really sure where to start I did
have this part figured out but I think
it's important to talk about scoping I
knew that I was going to be working on
our chat box but I think it's important
to ask these questions what is small
enough for me to cover with the time and
resources I have what could benefit the
most from updates and what has the
farthest reach and in my case that was
the chat box it was fairly well
contained the UI had been updated
recently to use react and redux so and
react lends itself very well to
accessibility it could definitely stand
to benefit the most because it was the
oldest application and it does have the
furthest reach if I had started with our
help center or our marketing pages or a
different front-end part of our our site
like our billing app or configuration
that would reach our customers and
that's a sizeable amount but it wouldn't
reach their customers so that's an
exponential reach there's our chat box
is on so many sites and it would help so
many more people than just editing our
site so then I took stock of my
resources I laid things on the table and
I said okay what do I have to work with
here
I had me I had one month I had this
amazing opportunity where I changed
teams mid product cycle which meant that
I had a month before the next one to do
something I was really passionate about
and that was accessibility I had browser
audit tools most modern browsers have
these audits that you can do similar to
the one that Britney talked about just
before this and one of them is
accessibility so you can run an audit
and they'll tell you all of the more
obvious holes that are in your website
things that you need to fix like this
image doesn't have an alt tag or I'm not
sure what this div does things like that
I could talk to consultants there are
many places that can do this this audit
for you and give you advice and are a
lot more have a lot more expertise than
I do but given the first two bullets
here me one month I skipped this part I
did consult the web I liked community
and they are wonderful and welcoming and
lovely and they helped me with a couple
problems that I wasn't quite sure how to
approach on my own and then I was found
out that I could automate some of this
through node modules and from the title
of my presentation I'm sure you know
that I'm going to talk a lot about axe
core and then react Alli is another
wonderful one I include both on load for
each of our applications and then it
will pop all of those audit results
right into the console as warnings so
it's really obvious when you know
something is inaccessible on whatever
component
part of your app you are working on in
whatever state it's in at that point so
this is everything I decided to bring
with me so again I'm gonna talk about
Acts for a second I was pretty biased in
choosing this particular technology
partly because it is created by DQ
systems which happens to be based in Ann
Arbor Michigan where I live and they
they in addition to having an awesome
open-source tool that you can use to
automate some accessibility things do
consulting and also do education I about
halfway through working on this project
I attended our free webinar that they
had called how persons with disabilities
use the web and it featured a panel of
people with varying experiences who
talked about their reliance on screen
readers and when you think about screen
readers or at least when I did in the
beginning
I I knew immediately that those with
blindness would be using the screen
reader but it didn't occur to me that um
you know those with lower vision or
those with short-term memory loss or
those who have traumatic brain injuries
those who are having difficulty
concentrating like those with autism all
rely on the screen reader also a lot of
people suffer from chronic pain and have
mobility issues and you know using a
mouse with that fine motor control is
really difficult for them and so
navigating by keyboard is really really
important and realizing all of these
different use cases really opened my
eyes to like all of these different
people that I could reach and how much
more robust I could make our application
so the other reason I'm biased here is
because Marcy Sutton look this woman up
she is the queen of accessibility works
on Act's core and she gave the first
success of lady talk that I ever saw at
jeaious comp us 2014
and she absolutely blew my mind and it
was something that I was sort of already
interested in but dislike clinched it
that I needed to be working on this so
my game plan here was to get explore
working with my testing stack run those
audit tools and all of my components
make sure it was included in my front
end components address those results do
some manual testing and then address
those so why did I start with testing
it's because um there are many reasons
but let's go through a few it provided a
structured way for me to start chipping
away at the problem in front of me again
I am a rule follower so if I have a set
protocol here I I know what I'm doing
and so automating this step instead of
me going through the browser and looking
what was in the console and you know
running through absolutely every state
of my app it's gonna take a lot of time
and doing this is way faster so having
this tool with which to like blaze my
path was amazing the other great thing
is that it's really repeatable so I
could put this in one component and then
copying my tests into all the rest of
the components and quickly see which
one's failed and fix those problems
really quickly then it even goes another
level because my team could look at the
stuff that I had just done and ported to
their projects and now all of their
projects were tested furthermore if I
updated any one of those components and
it broke my tests I would know that
there was an accessibility issue even if
you know I hadn't run it in a real
browser and technically my code looked
good so these were all reasons that I
wanted to start with text so let's talk
about what that actually involved the
main function that ax core has for
running an audit is called ax run
it takes context which is a section of
the Dom we are testing so you pass it
either the document that's on the Dom or
a specific node and then you give it
options like it's okay if we don't look
at color contrast right now or let's
ignore plain divs or let's look at these
specific selectors let's you know pair
down which ones we care about right now
and then you pass in a callback to be
called after the audit actually runs and
that result returns these results which
are arrays of what passed and what
didn't
so there's an array of violations an
array of what passed and I mostly looked
at that array of violations so this code
is based on a gist that I found of Marcy
Sutton's
I will be tweeting out resources at the
end of this where we automate those
tests and make a component that we can
just include in our test files and then
use it to run those tests and I tried to
make this as like stack agnostic as
possible so that it's not relying on any
one framework but note that it is in
CoffeeScript because I am one of the few
people that really likes CoffeeScript so
in this first one note that I am
creating a brand new context of the DOM
and this is used using a component that
I wrote that consists of very few
functions that I will also be tweeting
out synergist that used uses jeaious Dom
and so I created a new Dom I get the
document of that Dom I create a div and
attach it and then I mount my component
to that div and then I return the
wrapper the div and the DOM and I need
the div and the Dom so that later I can
clean up after myself because when
you're tweaking the DOM and your
mounting things and then you're changing
States it's important to make sure that
all of your tests don't get those side
effects
so afterwards I removed that div from
the Dom and I blow it away entirely and
here's the larger function which is more
complicated than it looks I mean it
looks more complicated than it is
and I actually run the audit I take my
node which in my case is usually just a
raw component I react for component and
then I return a promise and I run my axe
cores out run with that node and the
config and if during that audit
something goes wrong I reject that
promise and otherwise I try and assert
things and I want to make sure that
there are no violations so I assert that
there are no violations has violations
as false and that the length of the
violation list is zero and if that's the
case I resolved my promise my test
should pass otherwise I reject it so my
testing flow is pretty simple I required
this module that I've created my ally
helper at the top of the document which
is not in my code here but that's what I
did and then I say it shouldn't have
accessibility errors I've created a
pretty simple component here which is
just renders an image and it takes URL
and alt text as parameters and then puts
those into the image tag and if I render
the image component and I don't put
anything in the alt text it will found
fail my ally test which is awesome which
is why I started with the image
component because it's really easy to
fail a test without that alt text but
yeah that is the nitty-gritty of my
testing and this is awesome because it
caught a lot of my problems it worked
really well
this alerted me to the fact that all of
the SPG's in my project weren't properly
described and so a screen reader like
had no idea what they were it alerted me
to the fact that a lot of my inputs were
improperly abled and didn't have on
change events
what else this find of this family like
links that we were using as buttons or
things that had the wrong rolls all
sorts of things that you know I I could
have cleared on my own but it would have
taken me way more time and the fact that
this was repeatable and automated and
quick was really powerful
so with that past cleared I can see the
bigger issues in my application I could
figure out what I needed to move
physically manually so I'm just gonna go
through the UI of our chat box and point
out what a user should be able to do and
then what they were able to do using a
screen reader in the keyboard so here we
have a collapsed version of our chat box
above it is our attention grabber which
just bounces and draws your eye from
wherever it is on the page down to the
bottom right where the chat box usually
lives it's just a visual element and
then there's the actual chat button that
has some call to action text and an SVG
representing whether someone is
available a chat box or an envelope if
it's going to be asynchronous in
communication and it will be an email
instead of a chat that the user can
expect and they could get to that that
they could read that call to action text
they could see contact Madeleine that
gets the rainbow I can see a pretty view
but they couldn't really see the image
for the attention-grabber that SVG was
broken and knowing that the chat box is
there at all was really hard for a
screen reader user because if you're
using a screen reader in the keyboard
you're starting at the top left of the
page and you are experiencing the web
linearly which means that you are going
through a page from left to right from
top to bottom and where's the last place
you get bottom right so it's unlikely
that person even knows that chat is
available and there and so I have trees
to the left and I was asked why are
trees bad as because they're blocking my
view from the beautiful
rainbow so I get to find an effective
emoji that went was my wilderness theme
so here is a conversation in action user
can see that there is a button to end
the chat there is a button to collapse
the chat and then there is an text area
where they can enter the chat and press
ENTER to send it three rainbows but that
SVG at the top is a broken they again
can't see the attached file SVG or the
sin chat SVG the actual chat they can't
see it all unless they do a lot of heavy
lifting and as chats come in its just
radio silence from the screen reader and
then I have another red box here because
if the chat box opens which you can do
with JavaScript or you can do if the
chat is initiated from the other end not
the visitors end it will pull your
cursor from wherever it is on the page
and put it right here and how terrible
is that if you are like using a screen
reader and reading some part of the page
and then all of a sudden you're not
where you expect it to be that's a
horrible experience
so five trees and you know what because
this is the main reason that the
application exists chat I'm adding more
trees because it's making it harder so
here's an offline no this is after the
chat has ended and you can still see the
conversation there are a couple buttons
you can press here and then there's
message saying the chat is ended
you can press that button that says send
transcript you can press the button that
says write chat and you can press the
button that says start conversation from
the keyboard using screen reader three
rainbows however again you can't see
those SPG's
and you can't really see the previous
messages and you don't see the chat has
ended message and then even worse but I
didn't include this on the slide if you
click on send transcript or write chat
it pops up a module which is just like
on the Dom this is still on the Dom and
it lays it over whatever was there
before so it's the ten it is possible
that your cursor is trapped here and if
you continue to tab it will continue to
go in these elements and you won't
actually get to you know fill out the
centra and transcript form or do the r8
chat survey because you can get there
and that's terrible so more trees than
rainbows once again so here is our
offline chat box not here every times
I'd still have to hear from you you can
see that like a way message there is a
forum where you can enter your name and
your email and an actual note and then
send it that's all great however you
can't see which ones are required and if
any errors come up like if you type in
an invalid email address for example
that error message is not communicated
via screen reader at all again just
silence you'll have no idea what's wrong
and if you press send you you don't
really know that anything happens so a
lot of events aren't really making it so
I noticed I distilled all of this
information down into a few categories
there was some extra elements a lot of
stuff was on the page that you couldn't
necessarily see I had some navigation
issues I had those hidden elements where
things are overlapped and then there
were live areas the chat itself that
were totally inaccessible to a screen
reader so at this point I had assess to
the path before me and I had moved away
quite a bit and it was time to build
something new
and pruning is not something you think
of is building but I think everyone can
agree that some of the best pull
requests are those that have a lot of
removals so I looked at this and I said
what can go and this is something that I
talked to the web Ally community about I
was like okay I have this visual element
that sits above our chat box that's
called the attention grabber that's
supposed to bring your i from wherever
it is on the page down to the bottom
right but if someone has worked hard
enough to tab through all the way
through linearly to the bottom right of
the page and they get there that's one
more hurdle before they get to the
actual chat it's just another barrier
and they're like yeah hide that we don't
need that so sometimes in order to
create a good experience you do have to
exclude some things so that is Aria
hidden then I place some new trails like
I said it's it's unlikely when you get
on a page that you're gonna know
something is sitting in the bottom right
that might help you so one of the first
things that I did was to create a link
to the chat box and that link allows us
an ID on the chat box which allows us to
link from the top right to the top left
to the bottom right which is super
helpful
then there was adjusting focus and just
making sure that you know all of these
overlaid UI is respected what was on top
in both in tabindex and Aria hidden so
that you know someone's cursor moved to
where it needed to be depending on what
was on top of the chat box and here's
where it gets really powerful
turn-by-turn directions this is the
material that I used for my bridge there
we go our announcer and on the Left
you'll see are really simple div it's a
div with a paragraph in it that has some
text but the power is in the attributes
on that div tag aria-live is basically
saying how annoying should this div be
and i have it set to assertive which is
the most annoying
you can tell it to be polite or to be
off aria atomic means hey let the user
know when something in this div changes
and then the role of alert means anytime
something happens shout it out and often
with a chat box that role would be log
because a chat is a log of things but
this is a list of events that happen in
the chat box it's not the chat myself so
this gets the role of alert and then
this was hidden from the UI via CSS is
awesome clip functionality and my excuse
for making this extra annoying and an
alert was because I manually controlled
when we actually make those changes in
state so I said if the chat box is focus
add that event text to our list of
announcements then join that list of
announcements with periods and then dump
that list into the announcer and then
the announcer will read it out and if
otherwise just add it to the list of
announcements and when it's focused
it'll get dumped in and so you can see a
chat box here the user says hello there
the announcer reads out you sent hello
there let's say they deviate away and
they come back and messages have
happened it'll say Madeline is typing
Madeline sent hi how can I help you
Madeline sent sorry I'm back and if
there were errors it would say you know
or if the chat ended it would say like
chat has ended it would it would read
out all of these events and this is
really powerful this is wonderful live
regions are magic so again what does web
accessibility about how is what is the
what before I thought it was rules
it's about usability it is about making
sure that your actions are repeatable
that the accessible thing is the easy
thing that patterns are established that
someone doesn't lose energy going
through your site because it takes a lot
of energy to remember what the screen
reader has said and to get work your way
through a web
right it's about starting somewhere I
did not accomplish absolutely everything
our chat box is not quote-unquote a
hundred percent compliant but you know
it's part of the way there I chipped
away and now whoever follows me is able
to make more strides those steps add up
and that means that we can iterate on
this is if there's a small thing that
you can do in your project go for it
it's okay that you you know don't have
to do everything 100% so thank you for
listening to me
I can't get through a presentation
without showing my rabbits they are
fantastic and adorable my slides are
here I will be putting more resources
into them because I think my resource
list is incomplete at this point thank
you so much I hope I've sparked some
like inspiration in you to work on
accessibility because it's so important
[Applause]
you